[Música]
la historia comienza exactamente a las 6
de la mañana del 6 de abril de 1956
a esa hora los niños del mundo duermen y
yo y mis cinco hermanos menores también
estaba durmiendo yo tenía nueve años de
edad y el último de mis hermanos apenas
cuatro meses de nacido
de pronto siento que mi tío me dio julio
me despierta y me dice el sobrino
levántate lávate y vístete que vamos a
ir a ver a tu papá
un poco de mala gana y se lo admitido me
había pedido y en efecto él me cogió de
la mano cruzamos las calles de la ciudad
de ciertas a esa temprana hora nos y
llegamos a las puertas del hospital de
las mercedes que no debí existe
cruzamos el hospital y llegamos al fondo
a una puerta donde estaba un señor
parado posiblemente el guardián metió
hablo con él y le pidió permiso para que
ingresemos
en efecto ingresamos pero solo hasta el
umbral
era un cuarto bastante fúnebre semi
oscuro
vi algunas mesas de cemento
un par de cuerpos tendidos sobre esas
mesas y yo no sabía que era eso
desde el umbral mi tío me dice sobrino
ahí está tu papá anda a verlos
entonces le volví a hacer caso emitido y
me encaminé hacia esa mesa
en efecto vi que ahí estaba mi padre
estaba atendido
[Música]
como un terno negro una camisa blanca
y me llamó la atención que sus oídos sus
fosas nasales y su boca estaban
taponadas con algodón
[Música]
no entendí eso pero menos entendí que mi
padre estuviera allí inmóvil que no me
dijera nada
debo decir con sinceridad que no tuve
miedo pero sí recuerdo que sentí un
sobrecogimiento interior muy grande
y en mí todavía no muy desarrollada
intuición de niño sospeche que algo
importante estaba pasando sin saber qué
era
al poco rato me llamo omitido
salimos de ese cuarto después supe que
se llamaba la morgue
[Música]
se despidió del guardián y apenas
salidos me dijo
sobrino tú sabes lo que es la muerte
en realidad yo no sabía lo que era la
muerte aunque había visto varias
películas del oeste norteamericano donde
los soldados matan a los indios y todo
eso entonces dije que sí
sin saber realmente qué era la muerte
entonces mi tío me dijo
dos frases que marcaron mi vida para
siempre hasta hoy
y me digo sobrino tu padre ha muerto
y ahora tú como su hijo mayor
tienes que reemplazarlo
y tienes que ver por tu madre y por tus
hermanos menores
mi tío julio ya murió de modo que nunca
podré preguntarle por qué hizo eso
conmigo lo cierto es que eso existió y
con esa frase que me dijo
y acabó abruptamente mi infancia
a partir de ese momento
la responsabilidad hacia los demás se
convirtió en el sentimiento predominante
de mi vida empecé por sentirme
responsable por mi mamá y los hermanos
menores 5 luego me sentía responsable
por mis compañeros de estudios en el
colegio y en la universidad después me
sentí responsable por el pueblo peruano
por eso que ingresé a la vida política y
a la dirigencia estudiantil a los 17
años de edad
avance luego para sentirme responsable
por el pueblo latinoamericano a los 18
años asistir becado a un curso de
capacitación política para dirigentes
responsables de la defensa de la
democracia en américa poco me faltó para
sentirme responsable por la humanidad
entera tenía que ser un buen hijo un
buen hermano un buen estudiante un buen
profesional un buen ciudadano todo tenía
que hacerlo bien entonces sentí que algo
me estaba asfixiando pero no sabía bien
qué era
con grandes limitaciones económicas pude
hacer mis estudios primarios secundarios
y universitarios
podría contar muchas de esas
limitaciones basta con una nunca tuve un
texto escolar en mis manos porque mi
mamá no tenía plata para comprar pero mi
uniforme escolar que normalmente duraba
un año a mi me tenía que durar tres años
por la misma razón y pese a esas grandes
limitaciones económicas sin embargo
fui uno de los mejores sino el mejor
alumno de mi promoción en el colegio
ingresé con el primer puesto al examen
de ingreso a la universidad fui el mejor
estudiante en la facultad de educación
de la naciente universidad asia del
valle que durante los cinco años de
estudios
al final la universidad me otorgó el
premio de excelencia por haber sido el
mejor estudiante fue profesor en un
colegio secundario estatal el gane un
concurso de cátedras y fui catedrático a
los 22 años probablemente el más joven
del perú y asia el obispo de chiclayo
quiso tenerme como profesor me llamó
para que fuera profesor de filosofía
para los futuros sacerdotes de chiclayo
de modo que o milagro a la edad de 22 o
21 años ganaba tres sueldos entonces con
esos buenos ingresos pude ya afrontar
mejor mis responsabilidades y dividir
los ingresos en tres partes una tercera
parte era para financiar mis estudios y
mis gastos personales una segunda parte
para mi madre mis hermanos menores y una
tercera parte para
porque para ahorrar porque pese a los
éxitos que obtenían yo sentía que mi
vida se estaba transformando en una
cárcel dorada dorada por los éxitos pero
cárcel porque sentía que no estaba
viviendo mi vida sino la vida que los
demás querían que yo viva entonces
a muy temprana edad 17 y 18 años
pensé en el siguiente plan secreto esto
es como una carrera de postas
yo he comenzado la carrera por ser el
mayor
ha sido una injusticia de la vida que
también padre siendo tan joven pero
sería otra injusticia que yo por el
simple hecho de ser el mayor tenga que
correr como único toda la vida
justo sería repartir la responsabilidad
entre carrera y post bien empezado la
carrera pero voy a correr mi derecho y
luego le pasó la posta al segundo al que
viene y cuándo va a terminar mi trecho
cuando se cumplan dos condiciones
primera condición que mis hermanos
termine en el colegio con mi ayuda
segunda condición y mi madre y mis
hermanos menores quedan asegurados
económicamente y así louis y cuando el
último de mis hermanos estaba por
terminar el colegio fui a lima hablé con
el grado cultural de la embajada de mana
y solicitó una beca para alemania el
agregado cultural me dijo va a ser muy
difícil que alemania les dé una beca
porque solamente da tres becas para el
perú una para el mejor alumno del
colegio humboldt y las otras dos para
profesionales jóvenes que ya sepan
alemán usted sabía alemán no le dijo si
en chiclayo nadie habla alemán
entonces va a ser muy difícil que les
den
sin embargo inténtelo entonces me dio
los formularios vintage y cayó lo llené
y lo mandé por correo
un año después me llegó una carta en la
que me dicen que
nos complace comunicarle que el servicio
alemán de intercambio académico le ha
otorgado a usted la beca sobre esta
etcétera y tiene seis meses de tiempo
para preparar su viaje recién en ese
momento
y se publicó mi plan secreto era hora de
almuerzo pero le dije a mi mamá ya mis
hermanos antes de almorzar quiero
decirles algo y les conté entonces todo
lo que les acabo de contar a usted de la
carrera de postor
no tengo seis meses para preparar el
viaje yo había ahorrado durante diez
años y según el reglamento de su
institución tenía el derecho a solicitar
un préstamo por el triple del borrado
y con ese triple lo ahorrado 650 mil
soles ya podía comprar una casa eso fue
lo que hice compré la casa le dije mamá
esta casa es para ti solo alquilas y
vivir de sus alquileres lleva tu vida
tú y mis hermanos menores hasta que
empiezan a trabajar yo ya en europa veré
cómo hago mi vida entonces con esa
seguridad y esa confianza del deber
cumplido el 9 de septiembre de ese año
1971 partir del puerto del callao y
miren ustedes aquí tengo el boleto
del barco porque tuve la suerte tuve la
suerte de pescar
[Aplausos]
tuve la suerte de este pescar un pasaje
en el último viaje de pasajeros del
barco o por barco que hizo la compañía
italiana y está al mar desde el callao
hasta europa después de este viaje no
hubo ningún viaje más porque todos esos
por avión no por eso lo guardo con tanto
cariño ya muy bien entonces ahí termina
mi primera etapa y empieza la segunda
que quería narrar la segunda etapa
empieza en europa primer gran reto en
europa el idioma el cine pluma seis
meses ocho horas diarias aprendiendo
alemán en el instituto beauty son más de
1500 horas de clase
segundo reto la universidad de frankfurt
a la que me habían asignado
el profesor asesor de la fundación
alemana que me dio la beca me dijo que
alemania no reconocía los títulos
peruanos
si no solo como equivalentes a la mitad
de carrera y que si yo quería hacer un
doctorado en alemania tenía entonces que
estudiar por lo menos dos años más para
adquirir la equivalencia del título
alemán
lo mismo le habían dicho a un joven
profesor colombiano a quien conocí en
esos días también le habían dicho que
dos años más pero ya llevaba cinco años
y todavía no tenía cuando terminar dije
no a mí no me va a pasar eso entonces
pedí hablar con el presidente del
convento de exámenes de la universidad y
allá fui le dije mire yo no solamente
estudiado en el perú yo también he
trabajado incluso durante mis estudios
he ejercido la profesión dos escritos
libros y artículos 3
he tenido perspectiva activa en la vida
política y pública del país y cuatro por
encima de todo eso no sé lo que
significa mantener un hogar y ahí le
conté mi vida de ser reemplazo de papá y
mi hermano mayor y haber visto por mi
madre mis hermanos menores no entonces
le dije yo he asistido a clases en la
universidad y he visto que mis colegas
mi sexto los estudiantes alemanes me
aventaja en una sola cosa es el dominio
del idioma lo cual es natural pues
porque yo recién tengo seis meses de
aprendizaje pero de aquí a pocos meses
yo estaría en el mismo nivel pero
ninguno de ellos tienen los otros
méritos que yo tengo de modo que me
parece injusto que bien pongan al nivel
de un estudiante alemán
el hombre se quedó impresionado me dijo
todo lo que usted me dice un mantel o
por escrito por favor lo hice
lo hice y al mes me llegó la respuesta
lo tengo el texto en alemán no lo voy a
decir porque no me entenderían pero lo
cierto es esto que el comité de exámenes
de la universidad de frankfurt hizo una
excepción y me dio el reconocimiento de
mi título y la autorización para hacer
el doctorado en filosofía en alemania
entonces yo que ya estaba preparando
maletas para irme a otro lado decidí
quedarme en alemania y hacer mi
doctorado empresa que me duró cinco años
que se fue el tercer reto
hacer un trotar en alemania es
probablemente una de las cosas más
difíciles que hay en el mundo es no
solamente una tarea académica o
intelectual tienes un tremendo reto
existencial es un desafío de vida
gracias a dios con ayuda de esa beca
pude hacerlo
o sorpresa cuando entregué mi tesis y
ésta fue calificada por profesores
alemanas mi tesis doctoral en la
universidad de frankfurt recibió la nota
más alta del sistema académico alemán lo
que ellos en idioma latín llaman opus
exhibió obra eximia y en la ceremonia de
entrega de los diplomas y títulos el
rector de la universidad hizo hincapié
en ese hecho dijo que la universidad de
francos normalmente no entregue esa
calificativo pero que esta vez había un
excepción
y se le había entregado el locus eximió
a la tesis doctoral del señor juan
manuel gama de romero de chiclayo perú
gran sorpresa
[Aplausos]
la universidad y otras instituciones que
hicieron de inmediato contratarme pero
la sangre me dijo tú necesitas ahora
vivir tu vida esa es la razón de fondo
por la cual he venido a alemania ya
entonces ya cumpliste con el doctorado
ahora necesitas vivir libre coge tu
mochila y viaja por el mundo los viajes
van a ser tu mejor manera de conseguir
tu libertad y de vivir tu vida y así lo
hice y me tuvieron 10 años abusivamente
con mochila al hombro viajando como un
gitano por el mundo entero y ahí puede
comprobar que es cierto lo que se dice
que en los viajes aprendes de más que en
los libros muy bien hasta que la
universidad de farrapos 9 busco y me
convenció para que me presenté a un
concurso de cátedra
lo hice gane el concurso y a partir del
me convertí aunque no esta vez en mis
planes en profesor estable de la
universidad de france estaba asegurado
hasta el fin de mis días con todas las
seguridades del estado de bienestar
alemán con todo lo que no significa un
cierto desarrollo en mi cátedra durante
diez años
y de pronto sentí el llamado de la
sangre me fue muy difícil tomar la
decisión pero después de dos años de
lucha interior
finalmente el llamado de la sangre
mochis está probablemente me llamó
y me convenció de que volviera el perú
entonces presenté mi renuncia a la
universidad de frankfurt y eso fue pues
una sensación en el ambiente
universitario y hasta en la ciudad de
frankfurt era algo insólito que alguien
que había llegado
desde cero que había comenzado desde
aprender el idioma llegado tan alto en
su carrera dejar a todo eso para volver
a un país que encima de eso estaba con
todos los problemas del terrorismo y sin
tenerte ningún trabajo seguro ni nada
suelta la sensación que uno de los
principales periódicos de alemania que
es el frankfurter rundschau
publicó un informe sobre este hecho aquí
lo pueden ver aquí está la despedida de
una vida entre dos mundos no profesor
peruano
regresa a su país de origen después de
20 años de docencia en alemania o divide
en alemán entonces ahí terminó la
segunda etapa y comenzó la tercera
volvió al perú
aquí fundé mi hogar con una mujer
peruana peruana ya y
construí mi casa no ven eso en
villarreal todos los que viven en
chiclayo saben dónde queda eso y cuando
ya estuve instalado ahí vi que habían
varias cosas que no estaban bien en esa
organización tome la iniciativa moví a
la gente de las autoridades para cambiar
las cosas y de todo lo que movía e hice
lo más importante fue el paseo youtube
resulta que a lo largo de la avenida
chinchaysuyo había un gigantesco muladar
y cuando yo lo descubrí me quedé
asombrado y que la gente se hubiera
podido acostumbrar a vivir al lado de
esa inmensa cochinada con perdón del
término y que las autoridades no
hubieran hecho nada por eso o contra ese
entonces en un momento de puedo decirlo
de iluminación mística tal vez tuve la
visión y la idea concebir la idea de
construir el base o youtube mete 92 años
en darle vuelta a esa idea y cuando ya
la tuve madura para convertirlo en un
proyecto de inversión pública la sometía
con la presencia al pueblo ya las
autoridades para hacer realidad esa gran
obra de bien común la lucha nos duró
siete años
en siete años
conduje la junta visita al comunal del
villarreal que me habían elegido como
presidente
hicimos 84 asambleas de vecinos y 1.472
gestiones a nivel local regional y
nacional para hacer realidad esa idea y
ese proyecto
todo eso lo tengo apuntado por escrito y
debidamente registrado
[Aplausos]
entonces decidimos ahora el paseo your
tu que como ustedes saben la
construcción está terminada pero la obra
no está terminada porque todavía faltan
algunas cosas que para mi concepto
inicial son fundamentales y por eso hace
poco hemos formado un comité de
mejoramiento de paz y virtud y estoy
empeñado en que se termine con lo que no
se hizo todavía y sobre todo que se haga
la implementación de un programa
cultural de actividades permanentes en
el paseo de youtube el paseo your tu que
debe convertirse en una ágora cultural
la idea del libro en chiclayo eso debe
ser un hervidero de cultura ahí se deben
presentar al aire libre piezas de teatro
conciertos de música festivales de danza
exposiciones pintura de posiciones
gastronómicas etcétera es decir tenemos
diez universidades de chiclayo y no hay
vida cultural en la ciudad hay que
acabar con eso
[Aplausos]
y terminó con la cuarta y última parte
de esta exposición unas pocas
reflexiones nomás miren en la vida todos
nosotros aprendemos mucho yo también he
aprendido algunas cosas de todas esas
cosas que aprendido que hiciera esta
tarde dejarles unas tres o cuatro nada
más primera lección que aprendido
no hay paraíso bajo el sol todavía en
toda vida hay problemas 2
e
la vida es un proceso de lucha
permanente
la vida es también un proceso de
permanente aprendizaje
hay que tener la voluntad y la capacidad
de aprender no más
4 si hay algo en la realidad que no nos
gusta o que no está bien
tratemos de cambiarlo
si vemos que no podemos cambiarlo pese a
todos los esfuerzos hechos aprendemos a
sobrellevarlo sin amarguras
y aprendemos a distinguir entre ambas
cosas
y finalmente la última reflexión
no nos contentemos por favor no nos
contentemos
con reclamar con protestar con quejarnos
con lamentado no
tampoco por favor nos conformemos con
estar echándole la pelota a los demás y
menos esperemos que los demás vengan a
solucionar nuestros problemas tomemos
nosotros mismo la iniciativa y
transformemos el mundo positivamente si
queremos mejorar el mundo tenemos que
empezar por mejorar nosotros mismos como
persona muchas gracias
[Aplausos]